chris bassett
cracks the rotation for the oakland days
for the first time
since 2016. he is a swing man for them
and he has embraced the role
yeah he has you're going to see a lot of
arms and elbows
and you're gonna see a lot of movement
to his pitches so fletcher at second and
at the plate for the angels is mike
trout fletcher doubled
and now trout strikes out great
3-2 curve ball haven't seen one all at
bat saved it for that
moment after he fouled off the fastball
and if anyone wants a big day it's the
man at the plate
shohei ohtani making his first start in
almost 700 days
seventh pitch of the at-bat and bassett
gets him but there's some fastballs in
some breaking balls up and away on a
fastball and griffin canning
makes his first start of 2020 coming off
a rookie campaign that
battled injuries towards the end of last
year but he has very impressive stuff
and he is coming off what his coaching
staff calls the best
performance they've seen from him
and he deposits his first strikeout on
three pitches quick work
of marcus trout struck out on a big
curveball
over one two two
okay trout strikes out for the second
time i don't want to change up this time
two pitches the trout generally crushes
change-ups
and curveballs this is a potential
hit-and-run scenario too for oakland
yards in 1995 to a pitch rolled on the
right side there's nobody there it's
going to trickle all the way through
into shallow ride a tremendous read by
kemp he's around
second motors the third standing there
without a throw
well placed by marcus simeon he serves a
bounding single through the right side
of the azer threatening with runners at
the corners
and one out for ramon loriano scripted
perfectly
for ramon lariano oakland's best hitter
so far in the first several games
and he goes after the first pitch here
comes upton
to make the catch and fire it home but
kemp's got speed and he's in there it's
one nothing oprah
now matt chapman stands in 3-2 pitch
swung on drilled in the gap deep left
center field trout on the run
and it will go off the base of the wall
into score of simeon
up to second base is chapman an rbi
double
a loud rocket off the bat and it's two
nothing oakland
that was one of those well-hit baseballs
for the runner and scoring position this
time it wasn't elevated in the middle of
play it was lower part of the strikes
with a fastball and he rocketed that one
the angels
are in business here in the fourth
bassett's first pitch
bouncing ball to third backhanded by
chapman he's going to throw home
and upton is going to run down he
stumbles in a foul territory
and tagged out by sean murphy another
platinum play by matt chapman
on the backhand didn't hesitate to cut
off the run
and the angels remained scoreless a
fierce choice for paul's
and la stella had no place to go stuck
at second base
canna fly to ride his first time up
connects long and
gone marcana muscles up
for a solo shot it's three-nothing
oakland
saw a few too many high fastballs and he
got on top of that one
ball was middle middle and he just
gone moriana will take off there he goes
and the balls hit hard in the left field
of base hit loriano
on the move he will go around to third
and chapman is three for three
this is a seed off the bat of matt
chapman you can see lorianno picking it
up
he knows what kind of throwing arm upton
has and on the move he's got
no shot at getting him so loriano
cruises into third
well it's pretty imperative if the
angels are going to get anything going
it starts now in this inning
this is line to the center field and
that is going to fall in for a two-out
single
very compact swing and here it comes
swinging and a mess got him upstairs on
a cutter and petite wins the battle
it took 11 pitches but the a's keep the
angels off the board
angelton simmons was getting better
offensively every year from 2014 through
2018
[Applause]
and who's got it not in time
simmons falls nice limping
falls awkwardly over the bag he's safe
at first and they'll check him out
[Applause]
that's the old leap for the bag catch
the back end and rolls his ankle
you just hope he got off the ankle as
fast as he could is
that doesn't look good so simmons exits
two on
two outs and the best in the sport
three called got him looking trout can't
believe it
takes his helmet off has a chat with
adam amar and none of it matters is
joaquim sorya strikes out mike trout
with a couple of runners on and the a's
winning
three to nothing